right now this is all guesswork so far
okay which is nice to get an idea but we
need more than just guesswork okay so
question see I told you the questions
get harder what kind of tools do we have
in our mathematical toolkit to actually
work out what is the gradient function
of this thing not just like guesses and
sort of approximations through visual
tools what what actual methods do we
have to work out what the derivative is
okay first principle is the right answer
first principle is actually the right
answer for a lot of things so you should
learn to pull that out first principles
okay it'll have a pretty good success
rate what is first principle what's the
definition it starts like this
what's it equal to some limit as H
approaches zero
okay of what X plus h X all divided by
good okay
now by the way where does this come from
well witnesses do you come from why is
there a fraction yeah what does the one
of the numerator denominator of this
fraction represent rise over run good
okay so what we're doing is calculating
ingredients okay but we're doing this
cool calculus thing of taking the limit
getting an infinitesimally small point
and therefore you can say gradient
all right let's evaluate it with this
function let's go the derivative all to
the X
never forgets write it for you what's
when you make a big good sure
- evidence so far so good now
I can factorize right what do I fight
what's up yes
now what am I gonna actually have on the
top of my fashion forever your index
lawyers to the exercises actually to the
x times to the age so therefore what
I've got at the top is just this great
okay now what
what's usually our goal in first
principles why do we do this what's our
what's our we trying to achieve with
this algebraic monkeying around what do
we usually work towards you would try
that we try and get rid of the sky okay
so for instance when you're doing first
principle of this obviously the square
root of x what's that what's the trick
what do you actually do to get rid of
the H don't like okay
by the way seriously that's like an easy
to my question in the age of soup you
should be able to look at that and like
sneeze and the answer comes out of the
page that's how easy should be okay
think about there's a trick but your
short answer is we try and get rid of
this and then you got H equals 0 and
then a chance it comes now we have a
dilemma here don't we what can we do you
have an exponential function and then
you have this linear function of bottom
and they just did not mix in there well
in water right there unlike here where
you can do some operations and things
are mixed together and they'll simplify
out kind of stuck here you could do this
this would be nice why can I do this why
can I just pull that out
because to the X right what does it have
to do or how does this value change as H
approaches zero and the answer is it
doesn't
okay it's independent of H so that's why
I can pull it out it's the same deal
with like engine or some other kind of
thing so that's nice but not much what
we're gonna do you can think about what
function could you this is very
important because you've got an
extension so that - once again you've
got an exponential so one of the classic
problems having techniques with
Exponential's all knowledge is just to
flip around the other way and often that
makes it a lot easier to solve but we
will think about logs shortly but turns
out in this case because I'm not
actually solving for anything it's kind
of it is difficult if you introduce logs
it doesn't really make anything now
we're kind of out of what we call
analytical options right things will
actually allow us to work with this
algebra okay but we can still work with
it because I asked you to get these
things out right okay and usually this
is too tedious okay you read this up how
do you work out what it is
okay well as H approaches zero you can
sub it in one account what's happening
okay so just off of the psyche oh maybe
okay let's try so nice H
now what we want to do is we want to
take values that are close to the limit
and then we want to take them
increasingly closer to the limit you can
never get there that's kind of a point
of minutes right but if you get close on
what got hounds back so why do we try
some ideas that achieve and then you
should get a decimal let's go to on
let's get a five decimal places I think
that'll be enough to see how its
behavior okay we got that that nameless
dude what's it called what factor of ten
what magnitude close up I wonder if you
can decide when you feel like you've got
enough precision to say yeah I think
I've got I think I can bring you guys
with this thing now the first one you
put in a tent what's actually equal to
zero point seven one seven seven okay
let's go to five okay
has anyone done pointing one you'll cut
the it seems none you give these people
okay and the last one what okay all
right now if you like you can't go ahead
and do another value okay but you can go
to see it's sort of grinding to a halt
isn't it's deleting the thing that
limits do it's getting closer to
something this is what I haven't when
you come down interest you go to that
right you're getting closer to two point
seven one and even when you make much
much much closer or you compounded much
much more frequently you've got
increasingly lower gains now what is
this thing
do you recognize
now I kind of got excecuted reckons it's
been a fan but it is actually an
opponent number okay I it's just how
many years I've done you know
mathematicians by trade so I don't blame
you for like how could you don't know
this number is but it's important it's
actually look into it yeah I will tell
you about the analyst get used to it now
here's the point let's just let's just
go with that approximation su to the x
times zero point six nine so it's
approximately okay no what does that
tell us can you see now why when I drew
by gradient function I drew it below the
original function you see the derivative
on to the X it's just like to the X but
it's always smaller it's this factor
smaller
it's like two-thirds the height -
Thursday - Thursday huh all the way
along this is actually first thing that
you learn here but you get the idea okay
now how easy would this be to try and
boil this for other numbers what if for
instance we're trying to bid three
because you've got three on your graph
okay
how would it behave now because your
actual ready purchases your calculator
hopefully the numbers are sort of still
there we would do the same limit thing
okay let's try and get it to the same
degree of accuracy that we had the two
DX
wonder what you're expecting is it gonna
be so much attention to it it's all is
it going to be something else would you
expect to do something else and why
because you can kind of see what's going
on you may just go straight to this
value evaluate the limit when agent is
equal to that can anyone give you a
number
oh wait
anymore
did you expect that is that surprising
what is it tell you I don't have 3dx of
you but if I were to have three VX and
it's gradient function what does it tell
you about the way they relate to each
other the gradient function is always
going to be above the original it's
kinda interesting what would happen if
you did the next one what would you
expect to happen can you make an
educated guess I think it'd be above the
original still how much give me a number
work it out if you've got in your
calculator I think you only need to
change a single number don't you have
you got a reaction calculator
yep so you can see who love this
actually makes sense because how are you
shaking what's what's happening from
here to here right this is becoming to
the h minus one then it's 3d h minus 1
then 48-year expecting it to get bigger
because it's not as getting bigger now
this one was below one so that's why I
was below this is above 1 so that's why
it's above you are to expect that
there's some kind of sweet spot in here
we don't get something that's a bit off
but you actually get one that you
differentiate and what you get is look
like your original function but it's
about a month okay what might it be
okay now now all right I said I'd tell
you what this number one's right and I
can also tell you what this number is
and what this number is then I will put
683 and so on so that's the Mont well
it's pretty close
go ahead imagine you get natural log for
two so log basically this is log 3 this
is odd form they find a computer true to
you okay
but you can get pretty questions
hopefully you can demonstrate to us so
therefore can we generalize mathematics
our patterns so if I were to
differentiate some exponential with a
constant base and let's call the
constant a ok we said that it's going to
be just like your original function but
it's off by a factor
what's the factor it's this it's log all
what did that baseballs air should write
that full form to make a little clearer
because now you can see why you might
guess a magic number
okay what is it that's gonna give you
one it's gonna get bang on it's gonna be
some number where
that is equal to that a 74 what number
is log base 81 just rewrite it a so how
would I actually like that properly the
derivative of e to the X is e to the x
times log e which of course is one okay
all right all that to establish that
little important result okay so if yours
is like mine it is a bit of a bond zone
in terms of you're working maybe you
want to put that in separate blocks
color and highlight or whatever
separately so you can realize that it's
important and this one on the bottom is
sort of similar not quite as big but
they'll ask you a question about it so
this is for all Exponential's and this
is a special case where the exponential
is absolutely based that make sense